-You look gorgeous.
Thank you so much for
coming back on the show.
-I love your beard!
-You do?
-Yeah, you look very handsome.
-Thank you.
It's a new thing. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's the most masculine thing
I've ever done.
It doesn't really go with
my voice.
Thank you. You look gorgeous.
-I've never been here
in the chair.
-Just singing, just performing?
-It's my first time
in the chair.
-Yeah, I performed and then
I did the, what do you call it?
The Classroom Instruments.
-That was such a big deal
for us.
We loved it.
-That was your show...
-You sang "Let It Go."
-What was that, show 11?
-Brand new "Tonight Show,"
yeah.
You came on and did us a solid.
Not only that, by the way,
when we aired it,
it was the day after you
performed at the Oscars.
-Yeah, "Let It Go."
I have to say, that was cooler
than at the Oscars.
-Really?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, first of all,
my name got screwed up, so --
No, I'm just kidding.
-That was such a big deal.
Adele Dazeem.
-Yeah, no.
That was the greatest thing
that ever happened to me.
-That was wild.
-I'm not complaining.
-We've had John Travolta
on the show,
and we talked about it.
He was like, "I know, I did it.
It was embarrassing.
Can we get over it, please?"
-Yeah, but then we came here
and I played the triangle
and you played the --
-Usually they hand me,
I go in with an instrument
or a big drum or something,
and then everyone talks me
out of playing.
Questlove's like,
"You're off beat" or something.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
It's so distracting.
-Then they give me something
that makes no noise.
-Yeah.
-So I use that. I go like that.
It makes no noise.
-Oh, that's good.
-But you were so great that
I remember it, like --
honestly, your voice is
just so beautiful.
-Aw, thanks.
-You don't really even
need a microphone,
you just project.
-No, I work hard
and I have to practice a lot.
-I saw you at some charity event
a couple years ago.
-Yeah, where were we?
-You were onstage
and there was no band.
You sang acapella.
-There wasn't?
-And you knocked everyone...
-The good thing about that is
you don't have to worry about
being in the pocket, you know?
You just sing,
and if you're off,
you can sing in whatever key
you want.
It's like singing
the national anthem.
-I do that anyway.
[ Laughter ]
It's National Drink Beer Day.
I just get up there and sing.
But I mean, you crushed it,
and I was like,
"Oh, my gosh," and everyone was
just like, jaw dropping.
-Aww.
-Yeah, you've got it.
You're a talent.
Come on, you're amazing.
It's always good to see you.
I want to talk about your book,
"Loud Mouse."
-Yeah?
-I want to talk about this,
but then I was talking
to you backstage, and I go,
with "Frozen" and "Let It Go,"
do you ever go to Disney?
Do you feel weird
going to Disney?
-No! I love to go to Disney.
It's just sometimes they make me
do a photo op
with the Elsas and the Annas,
you know?
-Yes.
-But it's really uncomfortable
for me,
because I want to talk to them
like, I know they're probably,
that it's a day job and they're
aspiring actresses.
so I try to just be cool
and I say, like,
"Hey, it's really hot here.
You must be so hot
in that costume."
Elsa's always like, "Yes, it's
very hot here in Arendelle."
And then I'm like.
-You have to stay
in character the whole time.
-Yeah, they have to stay,
or they get fired.
I'm not trying to break them,
I just want to be cool,
you know?
I'll be like, "You want to go
for a drink later, after this?"
[ Laughter ]
And they're like,
"Olaf's a little underage
for drinking."
[ Laughter ]
I'm just like, "Forget it!"
-No, they can't break character.
That's right.
Look, here's a picture of you,
though.
They look good!
-I bought a tiara there
so I could fit in a little.
-That is so fun.
We had Kristen Bell on the show
not too long ago,
and she unofficially confirmed
with no backing
or no truth to it
that "Frozen 3" is happening.
-Yes, she did. Yeah.
[ Cheering ]
-What can you say on that?
-I can unofficially claim
with no backing
that there'll be
a "Frozen" 4 and 5.
-Wow!
You heard it here tonight!
The trilogy and
then the quadrupoly!
-I loved "Frozen 2," by the way.
I loved it.
I thought it held up to
the original and it was great.
I loved it, so we would love
a "Frozen 3."
-We have the best time.
You would?
I would love it.
-Yeah, I'd love it,
'cause I'd like to pay
my son's college.
[ Laughter ]
-But you just keep crushing it.
Besides that, "Wicked."
You've had some giant roles.
-Yeah, I try to do one
giant role a decade,
you know what I mean?
-And just own it and just...
-Yeah.
-"RENT," "Wicked," "Frozen."
In between, I just hang out
and go to my son's
basketball games.
-Yeah, there you go.
Just a normal parent.
I want to talk about
"Loud Mouse."
I have two --
-You have two little girls.
-Yeah, and I have
two big readers.
They love reading, so this is --
-Well, you're a children's book
author as well, right?
-Sure. I mean, you could --
Yeah, I have books.
-Oh, my God, you must
be the best,
when you read to your girls,
and the characters
and everything that you do.
-No. I...
[ Laughter ]
I wish it was more exciting,
but no.
My books have, like,
ten words in the whole book.
[ Laughter ]
It's basically a text message
with animation.
-No!
-This is an actual book
with a message.
-This is a book that I wrote
with my sister, Cara.
-Yeah, who I met backstage.
-Who you saw backstage.
She's actually a teacher
and a writer,
and she specializes in literacy
as a teacher,
so I didn't want to do
a children's book without her.
First of all, because
I don't do anything without her
and she knows me
better than anyone,
and also because I knew that
she would approach it
through the lens of a teacher
and the expertise and her love
for language and everything.
-Yeah.
-So she wrote
the most lyrical, poetic story,
and I inspired it.
It's kind of about
when I was a little girl
and I had this big voice,
and I was never really sure
when I could share my voice.
Like, I didn't want to call
too much attention to myself.
But the thing is,
you know, when little kids
or big kids, grown-ups,
when we want to be
seen and heard,
then we really are
and it can be very vulnerable,
and it's a lot of risk taking.
So that's kind of
what it's about.
-"With my tail in my hand,
my whiskers out proud,
I sing it big,
I sing it la-la-la..."
-She puts her tail in her hand
like a microphone, of course.
-And sings it loud!
-Could be anything.
It's not just me.
You don't have to be a singer.
It could be just any passion
that a kid starts to have.
-She does get loud,
and she gets embarrassed.
-And then some extraordinary
things happen
when she actually
shares her voice publicly.
That's what I'll say.
-And then it gets kind of --
It's good, it's a nice,
emotional thing,
and then it ends up like,
yeah, be loud.
Be yourself.
But you actually, of course,
which I thought is brilliant,
you wrote a song for this.
-Yeah, I wrote a song,
because there's a refrain,
and as my sister would say,
little kids,
if they can't read yet, it's
great to give them repetition.
So that's the refrain,
that Jimmy was saying,
you know, "with my tail in my
hand and my whiskers out proud,"
and then there's a part,
it goes, "La, la, la..."
Can I do it for you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We always have a microphone.
-Okay.
So when it gets to
the "la la la la loud" part,
you should go,
it's like a scale --
♪ La la la la la la loud ♪
But it's actually
so much higher,
because I wrote it
for a kid's key,
and I can barely sing it,
but it's -- ♪ La la la ♪
You'll get it when we get there.
-We can do it.
Sure. Roots?
-Can you give me a note?
[ Single note playing ]
Okay.
♪ With my tail my hand ♪
♪ And my whiskers out proud ♪
♪ I sing it big ♪
♪ I sing it loud ♪
Everybody!
♪ La la la la la la loud ♪
Come on, you can do it!
-Ohh!
♪ La la la la la la loud ♪
-Idina Menzel!
"Loud Mouse" is available now!
-♪ La la la la la la loud ♪
-We'll be right back
with a performance
from Babyface
featuring Baby Tate.
Stick around!
-♪ La la la la la la loud ♪
-Yes!
-♪ Ohhh ♪
-♪ La la la la la la loud ♪